(Leaves rustling)
(Light clicks on)
Ow!
Jimmy:
Release me!
Hello.
You're in my bushes.
Jimmy:
They’re really well-kept.
(Exhales)
How's Alice doing?
Liz:
You okay Alice?
I have to ask,
is this you forever?
I don't know.
♪♪
Bill Lawrence:
I always had in the back of my
head
writing a show about a-a
physician or a
Bill Lawrence:
therapist that was kind of
dealing with grief.
Excuse me. Sup, Jimmy?
Hey Gabby.
Brett Goldstein:
And I had an idea for a show
that was basically
a very, very dark version of
what this show is.
Who are these girls, Jimmy?
Are they hookers?
I don’t think so.
Did you pay them money?
Not yet.
And he said, why don’t we put
these together?
♪♪
Brett Goldstein:
We met with Jason, and we talked
about this idea for the show.
And then I thought very soon
after, he said, ‘Yeah, I want to
Brett Goldstein:
do this with you guys.
You meet Jimmy truly at
rock-bottom.
Jason Segel:
He's grieving the loss of his
wife.
♪♪
You’ve been acting like it only
happened to you, but it happened
to us.
Jason Segel:
Jimmy has really fallen apart
and is no longer a dependable parent.
You know who the most important
person in your life is?
You.
Your daughter.
Right, that’s what I meant.
I'm second.
Okay.
♪It's a new day tomorrow♪
Because of his grieving, things
reach a boiling point.
Jimmy:
You guys ever get so mad at your
patients?
(Mocking voice)
I get sad when I do this thing.
Haha.
-Maybe don’t do that thing!
Jimmy decides to start telling
patients exactly what he thinks.
What sets you off?
Everything.
You trust me, Sean?
-No.
Jimmy:
Doesn’t matter.
Let’s go find you someone to
beat up.
♪Take a breath and believe♪
Oh, he can use his feet.
Sean, he’s using his feet!
He’s gonna use his feet the
whole time, I bet.
I know that.
♪There's a wide, wide world in
front of you♪
If you don’t feel any grief or
heartbreak,
Jessica Williams:
then you’ve missed the point of
what it means to be alive.
Sometimes you’re crying, and
it’s very surprising,
but it’s very funny.
Aha!
(Crash)
Ahh!
I’m so sorry.
How are you already crying so
hard?
Oh, no,
I was crying before.
♪♪
Jason Segel:
Throughout the season, we watch
Jimmy clumsily
figure out how to rebuild.
Dr. Phil Rhodes:
Be me for a second.
Sorry for always being so hard
on you.
It’s only ‘cause I love ya.
I don’t talk like that.
(Crying)
Brett Goldstein:
It’s the journey of reconnecting
with
all the people that surround
him.
I was there!
I needed to hit rock-bottom,
Jimmy:
and you wouldn’t let me.
Jason Segel:
A really interesting theme of
the show
is by helping others,
we can somehow heal ourselves.
Bill Lawrence:
When there’s a big cloud of
darkness,
sometimes the only thing that
can yank you out
Bill Lawrence:
is making each other laugh.
Man, this thing I’m doing is
really working.
♪♪
I need you to be excited for me.
♪It's a new day tomorrow♪
I love you.
♪♪
Too much.
Yes, I know.